now that the dust has settled on the
liberal's latest indictment of President
Trump the precise nature of the charges
is becoming a little bit clearer they're
not getting him on a campaign donation
this time as they tried in New York and
they're not getting him on inciting an
Insurrection as they tried in DC
and they're not getting him on keeping
White House souvenirs as they tried in
Florida
in Georgia the libs are arresting the
former president and current leader of
the political opposition for
tweeting out a TV show
I'm not joking
this is verbatim text from the
indictment quote honor about the third
day of December 2020 Donald John Trump
caused to be tweeted from the Twitter
account realdonaldtrump
Georgia hearings now on oannn amazing
this was an overt act in furtherance of
the conspiracy
I'll get you tweet at a TV show you you
could go to the clink for many years
it's not just TV show tweets though no
no no this indictment also includes the
crime
of asking someone for an elected
official's phone number
here is another charge from the
indictment this one relating to former
white house chief of staff Mark Meadows
verbatim from the text of the indictment
quote honor about the 21st day of
November 2020 Mark Randall Meadows sent
a text message to U.S representative
Scott Perry from Pennsylvania and stated
can you send me the number for the
speaker and the leader of the PA
legislature
POTUS wants to chat with them
this was an overt act in furtherance of
the conspiracy
these are the kind of charges on which
the libs are building the case that a
bunch of Republicans including Donald
Trump engaged in a conspiracy to
overthrow our sacred democracy
but by the standards in this indictment
countless democrats should be behind
bars Al Gore and his supporters in 2000
Hillary and her supporters in 2016. by
this standard not only have Democrats
committed these sorts of crimes many
times in the past
but Stacey Abrams did it just five years
ago in the state of Georgia as far as I
know she still hasn't conceded that
election
the charges are flimsy and Preposterous
in a more civil and law-abiding age we
would laugh at them but that era of Law
and Order is over the very fact that the
charges are even being brought proves
that we no longer live in that
reasonably lawful country we are living
in an age of the raw exercise of power
and if the Democrats get their way Trump
will be one of the first but certainly
not the last to get a taste of that
power
to the tune of at present count
potentially
727 and a half years in prison I'm
Michael Knowles the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good Ranchers a great
meet at a secure price and 30 bucks off
your order with code Knowles Canada
w-l-e-s you can get the same delicious
steak I had for lunch like three days
ago it's just so
freaking good goodranchors.com use my
code Knowles today a jury has just
awarded a woman
1.2 billion dollars from her
ex-boyfriend because he sent revenge
porn out we'll get into the intricacies
of that case I love this decision we
will get into it in a moment first I
don't want to gloss over the Trump
indictment
I I know I have to be more specific than
that this is the most recent Trump
indictment this one in the state of
Georgia so this is not a federal charge
this is a state charge which means it's
going to be a little hairier for Trump
to Pardon himself if somehow they let
him get elected again and well we're in
Uncharted Territory so we just don't
really know what it looks like the
Georgia indictment though is not just
against Trump
George indictment is against Mark
Meadows former white house chief of
staff great guy
uh former Republican party chairman of
Georgia David Shaffer another great guy
former New York city mayor Rudy Giuliani
great common New Yorker so obviously
love Rudy and many other people
state senator Sean still attorneys John
Eastman a wonderful man Sydney Powell
Jenna Ellis my friend Bob cheely Ray
Smith III Kenneth chesbrough former
assistant U.S attorney General Jeffrey
Clark GOP strategist Michael Roman
former Coffee County election supervisor
Misty Hampton Coffee County GOP chairman
Kathy Latham Atlanta bail bondsman Scott
Hall publicist trevian Cudi Illinois
pastor we got of course we got a pastor
in there Stephen cliffguard Lee Harrison
Floyd who who ran for office the list is
so long so full of people a reminder
that this is not really about Trump
it is in that Trump is the lightning rod
Trump is the one who changed the GOP
Trump is the one who threatens the
liberal political order and so Trump is
getting all of the attacks and it's
ironic that it's Trump because the
Liberals love Trump for his entire
career and he was a big celebrity
fettered in Hollywood fettered in New
York
lauded in all sorts of hip-hop songs and
popular music the moment he decides to
be a Republican and a populist
conservative at that they all turn on
him but it's not really about Trump in
as much as
even if you're a republican who hates
Trump they'll get you to eventually
they'll get you two
this is a shift
and we're not going to go back to the
old normal
the Democrats have decided to make
political dissent illegal
even at the highest levels it's not
unprecedented in American history to
litigate the the fringes of political
dissent but we've obviously never thrown
a former president prison we've
obviously never thrown the leader of the
opposition in prison and we've never
thrown into prison all the people around
him that's what's going on here so it's
the criminalization of politics in this
case specifically conservative politics
I don't see how you go back from that
and if you're one of these Republicans
who doesn't like Trump or who thinks
it's convenient to distance himself from
Trump
I've just got bad news for you they're
going to come for you too Jenna Ellis is
is
promoting DeSantis right now Jenna's not
working on the Trump campaign she was
Trump's lawyer now she's and there are
plenty of Republicans who they work for
one politician then they go support
another politician but they don't care
here the Liberals they don't care
they're going to go after all of them
John Eastman very respected conservative
lawyer
Rudy Giuliani America's mayor
everybody they're going after everybody
now go after you two it's not just about
Trump and Republicans will join together
or die apart that's the way it's going
to go now when you want to build
yourself up for battle
metaphorically or literally if you want
to build your body up to be big and
strong you got to check out good
ranchers right now go to
goodranchors.com use code Knolls I don't
know about you but this summer heat in
Nashville feels hotter than it's been in
years and thanks to the inflation we are
feeling the heat in more ways than one
huh well the one thing I'm not sweating
this hot summer is my meat price thanks
to good ranchers my price is locked in
for two years you might be thinking a
price lock on meat yes it's amazing and
you need it how does good ranchers do it
I have no idea because they've got
higher quality meat than any other
company out there and their prices are
lower than all the other companies and
then they're locking it in even with Joe
Biden who is president inflation so I
don't know how they're doing it but it's
great and I eat this food all the time
and it's just so freaking good
everything they make is terrific the
steaks are out of control and the
burgers are the best I've ever had if
you want it and you want it for a great
price all good American meat go to
goodranchos.com use code Knowles kwles
us get 30 bucks off any box that is
promo code Knowles at goodranchers.com
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
so
Trump
uh now is is having his indictment hinge
on one little phrase the phrase is find
me the votes you maybe you've heard that
if by some chance you were walking
through an airport and therefore CNN was
on one of the TVs and you happen to hear
CNN or MSNBC or one of these liberal
channels they'll say that Trump called
the Georgia Secretary of State and told
him to find me the votes
so that he could flip the election in
that state
the problem for the prosecution is that
the liberal media are lying about that
phrase trump never said that
we have the transcript in fact if you go
to the CNN website you get the
transcript of this phone call between
Trump and the Georgia Secretary of State
and and some of the legal counsel in
that office and you'll see he didn't say
find me the votes he said something very
different
oh and in fact I'll read it in full this
is that's not in full this was a long
phone call but
this is a good chunk of the relevant
portion here so Trump says to the
Georgia Secretary of State Brad
raffensberger quote I think you're going
to find that they by the way little
information I think you're going to find
that they are shredding ballots because
they have to get rid of the ballots
because the ballots are unsigned the
ballots are corrupt and they're brand
new and they don't have a seal and
there's the whole thing with the ballots
but the ballots are corrupt very
trumpian kind of diction but the ballots
you know and the ballots and people are
going to say many people are talking
about the ballots and so he says but the
ballots are corrupt and you're going to
find that they are which is totally
illegal it is more illegal for you than
it is for them because you know what
they did and you're not reporting it
put a pause here I don't want to
interrupt it too much but you realize
here that Trump's diction is like it's
out of a David Mamet play
which makes sense I guess Mamet writes
like people talk in real life and maybe
it's a little exaggerated and it's a
special kind of New Yorkie well that's
Trump so he but he keeps coming back to
this goes but the balance but the
ballots but the ballots they're not
legit
and so he says you're you're not
reporting it that's a criminal that's a
criminal offense and you can't let that
happen that's a big risk to you and to
Ryan your lawyer and that's a big risk
but they are shredding ballots in my
opinion based on what I've heard and
they are removing machinery and they're
moving it as fast as they can both of
which are criminal fines and you can't
let it happen and you are letting it
happen you know I mean I'm notifying you
that you're letting it happen so look
all I want to do is this
I just want to find eleven thousand
seven hundred eighty votes which is one
more than we have because we won the
state and flipping the state is a great
Testament to our country because because
you know this is It's a testament that
they can admit to a mistake or whatever
you want to call it if it was a mistake
I don't know a lot of people think it
wasn't a mistake it was much more
criminal than that but it's a big
problem in Georgia and it's not a
problem it's going away I mean you know
it's not a problem that's going away and
then a lawyer in the Secretary of
State's office Mr Germany says Mr
President this is Ryan we're looking
into every one of those things that you
mentioned Trump says good
but if you find it you've got to say it
Ryan okay there's a lengthy bit from
this transcript but it's really
important because what you glean from
that transcript I think
incontrovertibly what you what you have
to
infer from that transcript is that Trump
believed
that the election was being stolen in
Georgia
and after all those reports of pipes
bursting and after the
count of the vote was paused in the
middle of the night took a lot longer I
think a lot of people were thinking that
and he said what I'm hearing is the
president of the United States this is
what I'm hearing is that ballots are
being shredded the ballots are not
legitimate that are being counted here
that they're moving the machinery and
that's illegal and he says I'm notifying
you I'm notifying you that if you find
that these things are true you have to
report it and I fear that you're not
reporting it but if here's the big if
that's the important conditional saying
if you find that that's true then you
have to report it
this phrase find me the votes he never
said it he said I just want to find
11 780 votes
he wants to find it because he was down
by one one fewer vote than that
and he's just said that he thinks this
this election is being
systematically egregiously stolen so
when he says I just want to find 11 780
votes he's not saying you better find
that number you better make it up he's
saying I think there are probably many
more votes
that are for me
but I just want to find eleven thousand
seven hundred eighty I don't even care
to uncover the scope of the corruption
here I believe that there is all of this
corruption but I just want to find the
bare minimum to stop this election from
being stolen
you might say well he was full of it
well there was no evidence of that well
I think this was the cleanest election
ever well there's no way that the
Democrats did anything corrupt in
Georgia in 2020. and you're entitled to
that opinion and that opinion is
completely irrelevant to the question at
hand the question at hand is did Donald
Trump engage in a conspiracy to overturn
election results and lead a coup daetan
and Insurrection in America and the
plain text of the transcript shows you
not even close
he very clearly sincerely believed that
this was happening a lot of other
believe that a lot of other people
rather believe that too
and he qualified he didn't say go out
there and find it this is a demand from
your president he says this is what I
want to find
and he even qualified his one demand
which was his legal right and frankly
responsibility to demand of the Georgia
Secretary of State he qualified it
he said if you find it
then you got to report it
if you find it and
the legal
Aid to the Georgia Secretary of State
says yeah we're looking into all of
those things okay
does that matter though
does it matter that this case is
preposterous I don't think so
haven't they crossed the Rubicon they've
indicted the former president leader of
the opposition
Joe Biden's own political Hatchet men
have done that
at the doj so I'm I'm not convinced that
the legal arguments really matter all
that much and George is not a favorable
place to Donald Trump depends on the
jury but but it doesn't seem very
favorable
now here's a little coincidence
totally off the question of the
indictments
cable news viewership sorry cable
viewership period has hit an all-time
low
right now if you take cable TV and
broadcast TV which is obviously a much
larger pool of people
it dropped to a new low in July 2023 in
terms of total share among American
viewers dropping below
50 of total TV usage in the United
States for the first time that's
according to Nielsen
cables share fell below 30 for the first
time ever losing a full share point uh
right now uh broadcast usage fell 3.6
percent which is down 0.8 points
year-over-year basis broadcast is down
5.4 percent cable viewing down 12.5
percent so way way down meanwhile
YouTube and Netflix just those two
companies accounted for a record 38.7
percent of U.S TV usage total
why do I throw all of those numbers at
you because now you've got
you're approaching parity between people
when they turn on the TV are they
turning on broadcasting cable or are
they turning on YouTube and Netflix and
Netflix is pretty lib but there's still
a wide smattering of on-demand shows
whereas cable and broadcast is pretty
much just what the networks want you to
see at any given time
I think that this is no mere coincidence
that the ruling class is clamping down
on descent more than at any point in at
least the last hundred years they're
doing it right now
at exactly the same time that the media
landscape is cracking up
the reason for that is this is a point
I've made on the show I haven't made it
recently but I I used to make it a lot
there will be order
power will be enforced
and if we in our communities are able to
maintain order
that's fine if we can't maintain order
then order will be imposed from above
but there will be order
and in recent decades really from the
second world war until 10 years ago
order was maintained not necessarily
with the heavy hand of the state the
police forces the doj and the FBI or
even the states and the localities order
was maintained in many ways through the
manufacturing of a consensus through a
liberal establishment media
where in the early days there were just
three news channels now there are more
than three news channels but they all
have the same talking points
statistically all of them are pushing
the same political propaganda and that
makes the people fairly docile easy to
manipulate and roughly on the same page
as that started to crack up as that
media Stranglehold started to crack up
yeah I'm thinking 10 15 years ago what
happens you start to see the rise of
populism on the right for the first time
in a strong way in a very long time you
saw the rise of the Tea Party you saw
the rise of the Maga movement them some
years later and and now you're seeing a
strong Conservative Republican party
that breaks away from some of the uh
orthodoxies of the
Republicans of the UNA party you know
there's this weird fact for years that
you could elect a Democrat you could
elect a republican you were always going
to get more in migration you could elect
a Democrat you could elect a republican
you were always going to Outsource more
jobs you can elect a republican you can
elect a Democrat you're always going to
get a lot more debt and a lot more
Foreign Wars and basically the same
foreign policy
and then you see these populist elements
creep in
I I don't think that the two are
disconnected at all and the the media
landscape is not going to come back
together anytime soon you're going to
continue to see a crack up and people
are going to look at this we're
broadcasting right now
in part on a traditional media landscape
on or at least on uh terrestrial radio
right now
but mostly this is in New Media
and then your liberal and
is watching MSNBC or CNN right now and
you are living in two totally different
media universes because we have two
different political Visions for the
country that are increasingly clear and
you've got two different political
communities in the same place and
right now the Liberals are the ones that
have all the power
and as we become a little more vocal as
we become a little bit more
um coherent and cohesive in our views
the Liberals are not going to tolerate
that and they are going to criminalize
not all politics just our politics and
they're going to make an example of
people and they might even throw the
leader of the political opposition into
prison and they're doing that in part
because they hate that opposition leader
they truly hate Donald Trump
but the bigger reason they're doing it
is because they hate you more
and they do not want you even beyond
their feelings of love and hate they do
not want you to threaten their power
it's enough to keep people up at night
you know why I don't stay up at night
because of Helix right now go to
helixsleep.com with everything going on
in the world right now you could use a
good night's sleep that is why you got
to check out Helix mattress he likes his
harnessed years of extensive mattress
expertise to bring their customers a
truly elevated sleep experience they
just launched their new Helix Elite
Helix Elite collection includes six
different mattress models each tailored
for specific sleep positions and
firmness preferences I've had my Helix
for years now I absolutely love it night
after night I sleep like a sweet
beautiful slumbering babe and I want the
same for you Helix has a sleep quiz that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
because why would you want a mattress
for someone else get out of my mattress
I'm a married man go to helixsleep.com
Knowles take their two-minute sleep quiz
to find the perfect mattress for your
body and sleep type they're flexible
payment plans make it so that a great
night's sleep is never far away Helix is
offering 20 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners hurry
over to helixsleep.com Knowles kwles
with Helix better sleep starts now
speaking of staring at screens
this is a feel-good story
the jury
in Texas just awarded a woman
1.2 billion dollars after her boyfriend
engaged in revenge porn
now before you say that seems a little
steep 1.2 billion that's a listen there
are a lot of people who don't even have
1.1 billion dollars you know much less
1.2 before you say it's a little steep
this guy wasn't engaging in
run-of-the-mill revenge porn I think all
revenge porn is pretty egregious and
should be punished pretty severely but
this guy was obviously a complete
lunatic uh the the ex-girlfriend filed a
lawsuit
which alleged and I guess the court has
ruled in her favor that this guy created
a website and a publicly accessible
Dropbox folder and fake social media
profiles to disseminate
porn of this woman
how did he get the porn you might say
well that woman shouldn't have sent him
naughty pictures that's not exactly what
happened the guy
obtained the porn
by accessing security cameras in the
woman's home
and taking pictures and video of her
when she was unaware that's according to
the Washington Post
then he he emailed her and said you will
spend the rest of your life trying and
failing to wipe yourself off the
internet Happy Hunting
he continued to just harass this woman
and try to ruin her life he's obviously
really really sick really perverted guy
and a psycho in all sorts of other ways
and anyway after this long and drawn out
breakup he he decided to uh
just try to ruin her life so the jury
Awards her 1.2 billion dollars I think
this is great
it's fine you know this is really psycho
behavior and people who engage in it
should should have the steepest
punishments the other reason this is
really good just from a political
perspective is
in this decision this court is
acknowledging the value of Honor which
is something that democracies in general
don't always place a high enough value
upon and degraded democracies that that
degrade into mob rule or oligarchy or
something like that they really don't
place value on honor
one of the pitfalls of democracy is that
it it can become too materialistic and
it can be become too full of envy and
resentment to focused on just stuff and
coveting other people's stuff
and what this decision says is
look what happened here is a guy spread
some pictures of his ex-girlfriend
around
it's not like he went and stole her
her car he didn't steal her laptop he
didn't steal her jewelry he stole her
honor he stole her reputation and what
the jury is saying is
had he stolen her car they might say
okay he owes you 20 grand stole some
jewelry okay he owes you five grand
stole some but he stole your honor well
he owes you 1.2 billion dollars
that's good we must
restore a sense in this country of the
importance of honor and the importance
of modesty why is it a big deal that he
got some naked pictures of her what the
Liberals will say is well because she
didn't consent to it
sure that's that's part of it
but consent is not the only moral
Criterion of course it's not the most
important one not by a long shot
if it were merely a violation of consent
that would be serious would it be 1.2
billion dollars serious
no I don't think had he just taken a
picture of her sitting on a beach
well that's a bad example because she'd
be wearing a bikini if he took a picture
of her sitting in a burqa and posted it
they might say well that's creepy and
weird but we're going to award you I
don't know 100 bucks 200 bucks 300 bucks
no one would be would be awarding this
woman 1.2 billion dollars they were
warning her that money because
they're acknowledging that modesty is a
virtue it's valuable people cherish it
and when that is taken away from
somebody that is a more egregious
offense and a mere violation of consent
it's a really good decision I'm not sure
that this was all conscious in the minds
of the of the judge or the were there
jurors here I'm not even sure but but
that is the effect of the decision and
it's
it's something that you see this in the
the Trad wife movement you see this in
the movement away from feminism and some
aspects of the sexual revolution in a
way you kind of see it with the metoo
movement which fizzled Hollywood made
sure to stamp that one out real quick
destroy their whole business model
threaten their whole business model but
you you saw those inklings there a
turning away from this shallow language
Liberal Liberal libertarian kind of
language that whereby consent is the
only important
moral category no
there's there are more important things
honor is important too
speaking of women's issues
so I didn't believe it the first time I
saw it
I played it on the show yesterday and
some people didn't believe it either
a spokesman for the Ukrainian military
is an American
[Music]
the American left
this is going to be controversial I
don't even know if I should say this
I'm going to irritate people but I'm not
here to Pander to you okay
I'm not here to tell you just what you
want here I'm here to tell you the truth
there's a study
shows that
half of U.S residents have tried
marijuana okay
I puff the devil's lettuce once or twice
in my wayward youth all right we've all
tried it
half of us I guess have tried it okay
I'm not listen people make mistakes
they experiment
17 of Americans currently
regularly smoke the sin spinach the
Peruvian parsley
California cumin you know what I'm
talking about
Jazz cigarettes you know what I mean
hashish is Hash is actually a little bit
different you know the Haitian oregano
talking about pot man they smoke it this
is according to a new Gallup survey
released on Thursday and I know before
I'm not I'm not gonna go
get on my high horse start talking about
how
pot is bad
and makes you
kind of
chubby and lazy and less funny though
you think everything else is funnier I'm
not gonna get on that highways
but to the people the conservatives who
say oh it's totally fine legalized pot
have everyone smoke I just have one
question this is a just a basic
political question do you think
that
the spread of marijuana use is likely to
make a more Americans more conservative
or more liberal
what do you think
do you think just all things being equal
you got a guy he's kind of politically
neutral and you say hey buddy come on
over here to the cigar bar and we're
going to talk about GK Chesterton and
Edmund Burke or you get a guy say hey
buddy come on down to the cool bar and
we're gonna throw back some beers not
Bud Lights and we're gonna hang out with
the boys and play poker
okay that's gonna push a guy into a
certain culture
or you say hey buddy come on over here
and start ripping out of this bong and
then we can all be in a drum circle and
engage in witchcraft like what
direction do you want to push people in
do you does anybody seriously believe
that more
potheads is going to make America more
conservative well if it's not if it's
obviously going to make America way more
hippie and dippy and liberal
then why would we be encouraging this
well
say the Libertarians well
Big Smoke dope
what right what right you think James
Madison wrote a right to smoke pot in
the Constitution I don't see that
what right the right that
Russell Kirk and Ronald Reagan and I
don't know any any conservative you name
John Adams and every any conservative in
American history you think
they really believe there's some
fundamental constitutional National
right to
smoke pot no obviously not
so what it so why would we want it
cut it out guys just gonna make people
big Libs
speaking of cultural influence we have
some great cultural influence from that
good old boy from the south who has that
that song about the rich men from
Richmond
which we'll get to in one second that's
my little tease before the sub rank but
whether it's changing the definition of
words or trying to convince you that two
plus two equals five sometimes feels
like the current culture is doing its
best to make you stupid when wokeness
permeates every aspect of your life it's
hard to know where to turn for guidance
well I've got some good news our friend
Dennis Prager has answers in his daily
wire plus series Prairie umasters
program
in master's program
Dennis has gathered 40 years worth of
wisdom and is sharing it on a number of
wide-ranging subjects Dennis offers
useful advice on marriage happiness and
how to be a good person
plus so much more he even dares to
explain the differences between men and
women in a world that wants to make you
woke
Dennis wants to make you wise all
episodes are now available but only for
daily wire Plus members so don't wait
go to dailywordplus.com become a member
and watch prageru's master's program
today
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Garrett Harriman 633 who says I just
want to know how that mother effort
wasn't real what did she see
I know I wanted to do that too I was so
dismayed that she put out that apology
video and she didn't do it just to get
attention she did it because apparently
journalists hounded her down and
ferreted her out and I think it's just
so
sad that they did that it's so
irresponsible there is absolutely no
public interest in finding out who this
poor woman is who had some kind of
psychotic or pharmaceutical or otherwise
just embarrassing episode on an airplane
there's no public interest in that other
than to humiliate her and ruin her life
I was very sorry to see that I'm sorry
to say that she apologized
she as far as I can tell unless she was
in full
control of her faculties and she just
decided to put on some performance art
she didn't really have anything to
apologize for and
I kind of want to know what she saw
but alas I'm not I'm not even going to
invite her on the show because I don't
want to make her life worse than it is
uh speaking of cultural influence
Oliver Anthony
Oliver Anthony is the singer
behind the song about the rich man from
Richmond and I I perused his YouTube
channel because that song is good he's
obviously a real talent it's not you
know it's I it's not the greatest song
I've ever written but he's a real talent
I loved that the song went viral he
seems great and I was perusing his other
songs his other songs are better than
the one that went viral
his other he's he's a he's just a real
musical Talent he's got this great voice
kind of like Levon Helm he's a terrific
little dobro guitar player and his other
songs frankly are even more musically
interesting and more my style at least
my style is probably not indicative of
popular music tastes so maybe that's why
the other one went viral but maybe the
best thing that guy has done is he was
just opening up a show his first show I
guess since all of this went down and he
opened it up by reading the Bible
before we start singing and I mean we
because I hope y'all are going to be
singing too
[Applause]
I just had something I felt compelled to
share with you
this is in psalm
Psalm 37 12-20
the wicked plot against the righteous
and gnashed their teeth at them but the
Lord laughs at the wicked for he knows
their day is coming
it goes on and on he reads this long
Bible passage
and I thought this is great and by the
end people applaud
very chat woohoo and then he starts
singing a song this is really great
stuff
because
it shows that this guy's purpose is not
just to make money
this guy's purpose is not just to become
famous this guy's purpose is not just to
get his one song out there
this guy is doing all those things
I can't even imagine how much money this
guy's made in one weekend when he went
that Viral got the number one song in
America he obviously got very famous
a lot of people have heard his music
he would seem from just that one little
clip he would seem to be doing it not
just for his own self-aggrandizement but
for the glory of God which is really
what it's all about I just love that I
just love that I've been going back
through Aristotle's Nick and McKeon
ethics narrow subtle points out all
these different kinds of Virtues and he
says you know wealth is not a virtue
it's nice to have material stuff oh you
need it for a happy life you need some
material stuff but it's not it's not a
virtue because it's not for itself it's
an instrument wealth is just there to
get you something else
but this is true of so much your
professional success what's it for
so that you can hang a trophy on your
wall at the end of the day so that you
can get employee of the month
what's it for
Fame what's it for way so that people
can be nice to you when you walk down
the street
and so people can ask you for pictures
what's it for is it
to bring glory to God and to bring
people closer to him that's ultimately
what it ought to be for right
and that appears to be what he's doing
seems to have his priorities in order
now
that brings me to the other populist
candidate in the race not Trump but
Bobby Kennedy Jr someone who does not
seem to have his priorities in order
uh RFK Jr has gained some support on the
right
because he opposes some of the
corruption in the Democrat Party he was
right about kovid he's right about big
Pharma and some of the the capture
corporate capture of the federal
Regulatory Agencies but but RFK Jr now
that he's being floated as a potential
running mate for Donald Trump was asked
his views on important issues that
matter to conservatives notably the
issue of life and abortion here's
Kennedy's answer
were in the Roe president if you were
president I believe that
a decision for aborted child should be
under the women during the first three
months of black so you would cap it at
15 weeks
yes or 21 weeks
three months so three months you would
sign a federal cap on that
yes I would okay so not unlimited access
to abortion as many in the Democratic
party uh you know one's a child is
viable
outside the wall I think that in the
state has an interest in protecting that
child and is that supersede and you know
I think that the state is an interest at
every level but at some point
I don't you know I'm against I'm for
medical freedom I think individuals
aren't you know able to make their own
choices this is why I'm surprised to
hear you say you've happened well
because you know I think at some point
you say to say I would personally not
I think the states
um have a you know have a right
who uh to protect a child once the child
becomes
very sad answer very sad answer because
it's totally incoherent
and
the reason it's incoherent is good
actually it's because Bobby Kennedy is
not just a run-of-the-mill Democrat who
just regurgitates all the crazy Democrat
points which now the Democrat talking
point on abortion is that we ought to
have abortion to the eighth trimester
you know it's should it's a wonderful
thing and we should celebrate it and
Kennedy's saying no no I don't I don't
think that I mean I support it
I support abortion I'm not one of those
crazy pro-lifers but I support it for
the first three months it's okay
she says only three months huh he goes
yeah yeah well the first three months of
life oh hold on wait you're saying
you're admitting that that it's life
that you're ending a human life in
abortion
so he's already he's kind a little bit
approaching the pro-life side he's
obviously at least open to it this is
but no but but you should obviously
oh I'm a Kennedy I'm a Democrat I have
of course abortion's good
but it is a life but okay so
really little really vulnerable life
it's okay to kill that but the older
life no the state has an interest in
protecting that life hold on so you
think she asks him you think that
that you shouldn't be able to have an
abortion later on that the state should
stop you well I'm for medical Freedom
huh so my proportion
well I'm for medical but I don't but I
don't think we should kill babies all
the time and well but
but I would I wouldn't personally oppose
abortion you personally I'm fine with
abortion up until the moment of birth
but I just think and you can it's just a
man who doesn't know what he thinks
about it which is fine so I don't want
to be too harsh on him I want to be
encouraging of Bobby Kennedy to just
examine this issue further and follow
his
I think probably correct recent
intuitions on this issue to their
logical conclusion if it's human if it's
life
if we want to protect people supposedly
his entire career is about protecting
people and the environment and from
predatory pharmaceutical companies then
you got to protect life you got to
protect human life as simple as that you
got to be pro-life he doesn't know that
so maybe he could get on our side
someday maybe not I don't know uh but
he's obviously not on her side now and
it's just a reminder that
it's encouraging to see him oppose some
of the craziness on the left but
it
he's not there yet he's not going to be
Trump's vice president he's not going to
be any Republicans vice presidential
running mate
uh
Kennedy's great contribution to this
race is to show that there is discontent
in populism serious populism 17 of the
party even on the left and that should
make us happy now when you want to be
happy
what do you do
my friend Dr Gad sad has some thoughts
on work Wednesday the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code Knowles at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
we'll see there
[Music]
foreign